people can't be expected to go vote
that'll be very busy
so they we have to have nationwide mail
and ballots and that
we are told is not going to result in
any voter fraud that's what the left
tells us
even though we've been prosecuting cases
of obvious voter fraud just in the past
couple months
well in atlanta
the tim's family ron timms goes to his
mailbox and he takes out his
voter registration mail-in voter
registration he got one
it was a card for cody tims cody's cody
his wife
cody his brother cody's one of those
names you know kind of cuts either way
is cody his son no cody is his dead cat
who died 12 years ago here is uh ron's
wife carol
describing the cat a great cat indoor
outdoor
loved his family loved the neighborhood
he was 18 and a half when he passed away
we have a voter registration application
for cody tims
how'd this happen i mean it's not
reality he's capped
here he is and he's been dead for a long
time there's a huge push
but if they're trying to register cats
i'm not quite sure who else they're
trying to register
i don't know if they're registering
dogs it could be dogs what's next
it's the slippery slope democrats have
always relied on dead voters to win
elections we could trace this back at
least
to john f kennedy in 1960 sometimes they
rely on dead people to be their
presidential nominees but they've always
relied on dead voters but now they're
taking it a step further more brazen
they're relying on dead cats if we grant
the premises
of the masks and the lockdowns and the
schools and all these little things
it's not a coincidence it's not just by
accident
that we will end up granting the
premises that will give
the left a major political and cultural
advantage even as
other countries that don't have
presidential elections in three months
are reopening and everything is going
just fine over there wonder why
i guess sweden doesn't have a very
highly contested presidential election
this year
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description